hey everybody welcome to the latest
edition of just getting started i am
your humble host rich eisen sitting
in the host chair for a good show a fun
show
and fascinating show a very
introspective edition of just getting
started this man's origin story
is quite fascinating but only perhaps
more fascinating by his complete
reinvention
as somebody who's got a massive twitter
following
that's uh shown up for his sense of
humor as well as his political takes
and then of course his positivity what
he
exudes on his twitter feed at rex
chapman
is something that has caused more than
seven figures of followers to come flock
to him and see what he's got to say and
put some neat stuff in our timeline of
course many of you might know rex for
his basketball playing days at the
university of kentucky or his decade
plus
in the nba and his story and what he's
done
to get to where he is where he's been
and how he got out of it
is perfect for just getting started
because the man got started like the
house of fire in kentucky and then the
nba
that fire got doused by an addiction to
opioids
and now he's somebody who's got a great
story to tell
i can't wait for him to share it right
here on just getting started
[Music]
here he is my guest on this week's just
getting started is a man who you enjoyed
again as i mentioned at the top in his
basketball career but what he's doing
now
through his social media feeds as well
as his podcast the rex chapman show
um is um is second to none and it's
something that we need in this day and
age is somebody
speaking his mind while also injecting
some positive into our world he is rex
chapman how are you rex
i'm great rich uh thanks for having me
this is an honor man
i i know that this is a little bit of a
this is a different kind of pod
yeah yeah i'm all in i you know i
as you know i can't i think i do because
i ask people
to come on my pod come on my pod is kind
of the new
read my script
yes so but so when something that's a
little different comes along
it piques my interest and i know this
one's a little different for you
well i appreciate this and as uh i say
this in advance
um you know this could be the home of
the home at home rex i'm more than happy
to
return the favor because i know you do
your pod with uh
josh hopkins or is he as he is known on
his instagram feed mr
mr joshua um and um
the actor um is uh in him is only
surpassed by the human
i've had many a fun night right uh with
josh hopkins he's a good
an amazing dude he introduces himself as
uh the guy on the show with courtney cox
not called friends
[Laughter]
he was great in cougar town i mean that
is true
these are not uh these are not wrong
facts to point out he's a talented
talented dude
but you know it's interesting because
again um starting this pod
two months ago or two and a half day
they all bleed into each other these
days
you know i wanted to start something
that is different from what i do
on a daily basis where you know you've
been on my
my regular daily radio tv show where
there's 15
20 minutes and clearly you know we will
talk a little sports here
um but you know we can't get in depth
into what
makes people tick and the thing that i
wanted to bring to
a lot of people's mindsets certainly
with the pandemic having hit
hard for so many people and before all
that
life was tough for so many people and
things getting tougher is that
you do have within you um the ability to
turn a page you do have within you the
ability to set your mind to something
new and try
to as the title of this podcast goes
just
get started just getting started and
everybody's got an origin story so let's
start with yours
um how when did you first realize
that you could play or when did you
first realize
that you had a gift rex oh man i
for basketball i guess is what you're
you're talking about
i i guess from a young age i my dad
coached basketball so i started going to
his practices
from you know kindergarten first grade i
would leave school and take the bus over
to
high school where his practices were i'd
do my homework while these
teams were practicing usually rushing to
get my homework done
but i would watch it and you know he had
i thought
really good players and actually one of
the couple of them were jeff
jones who ended up going and being ralph
sampson's point guard at virginia played
for my father in high school
so i grew up watching jeff jones play
and i started learning to dribble
between my legs before i knew it was
hard
you know when i was five so by the time
i was seven i could really do all that
stuff
i i knew that i had i was skilled but i
was never
a great athlete until probably
middle of high school and at that point
my athleticism kind of came together and
i guess around that time i started
knowing that i was
i was better than you know most of the
kids in my grade
and so uh when did kentucky come
knocking on your door
louisville was first and i grew up a big
louisville fan i was daryl griffiths my
all-time favorite
uh guy and so it was a big thrill to
you know end up playing against him in
the nba for a couple years
ultimately so uh but i grew up a
louisville cardinal fan
and they were closer to owensboro where
i was from they started recruiting me as
a sophomore
early in my sophomore year and i had
told denny crum you know i'm coming to
louisville and then right at that time
joby hall resigned
from kentucky eddie sutton took over
they asked me to come for a visit i went
for a visit
and my grandmother lived in lexington
that that helped
and but yeah it was going into my
well i guess going into my junior year
of high school
they came calling and then pretty much
you know all the other schools did too
but
and i had a real fascination with
carolina from growing up i
visited carolina nc state you know
jimmy v came to my house for an in-home
visit was that like
i'll tell you exactly
it was the middle of the day i came home
from school one day
i went in the house i saw a car was
parked outside
and i started to go out there and
as soon as i started to walk out to see
who was in the car
jimmy v he's in this car and he's going
and he's pointing at his watch saying no
no no you can't i can't talk to you yet
and he was waiting for midnight it had
to be midnight before
illegally he could be there and talk to
me but he was there
you know he'd come from raleigh durham
and i'll never forget
him coming into the house and say
finally and
talking to me and my mother and father
and he said you know what do you want to
study in school rex and i said
business and he slapped me in the face
and said business we got the greatest
business school in the world
he said everybody's going to tell you
the same thing it's going to be just
like this
right in the face and sure enough
everybody did we got the best we got
this and that but it was amazing so uh
you know dean smith came into my house
and uh i remember
what was what was crazy was um he well i
didn't know but my father apparently
knew because my dad
mom were long-time smokers all the way
through high school they smoked
uh while i was growing up and we'd been
sitting there for about a half hour
dean's
sitting there roy's there young roy who
did much of the recruiting roy williams
um and uh about 30 minutes into it my
dad just looked at dean and said
all right let's go have a smoke and they
went out and stayed for two hours on the
front porch just them talking left me
and roy and my mom inside
and they were just sitting out there
talking basketball smoking cigarettes so
way cool man so did your dad
and dean smith go four corners on the
rest of you is that what you said
they did they put it straight into the
four corners isis
played the clock out played the clock
out
how about that and jimmy v sat in a
parked car till midnight
to talk to you make sure he did it all
buttoned up
right there on tamaracking road uh yeah
it was crazy
real real it was kind it was kind of
surreal
we lived in owensboro kentucky which is
for kentucky is
town of about 60 000 at the time it was
probably the
third biggest city in the state and so
um but still having those guys
bobby crimins and and every co
every famous coach in the country come
into our cafeteria and sit up on the
stage with the teachers
um you know it was a big deal for for
owensboro kentucky and for me
of course yeah it was exciting and for
people's frame of reference what year
was that
that would have been oh man mid 80s so i
went to school
in college in 86. so this had been 84.85
in fact my mom just the other day yes
she dropped off a bunch of boxes that
had been in storage
and i pulled them out literally
yesterday
um unopened mail from
carolina kansas um all of these
coaches back when you had to do the
letter mail
um there's there's hundreds of letters
uh just sitting there i'm gonna go
through them at some point and see what
everybody was talking about
so you technically told dean smith no
when he just won with jordan
that's why i'm trying to put this all
together pretty much
that right after that yeah right after
that though
um my you know michael was in the nba
and and so
i came home from school one day and my
uh
at this point i really was i was down to
three schools kentucky carolina
and uh uofl and
my sister was on the phone she was a
grade younger right
and this was not great for either one of
us
you know peop high school kids who want
to be on the phone all the time anyway
um the the the phone was off the hook
from the recruiters
all the time and i'd gotten tired of it
but my dad made a rule that hey if
recruiters call
you gotta get off the phone jenny jenny
my sister so
she hated this rule and apparently i was
home one day
she was on the phone she clicks over on
the other line and says hello and
voice says hi this is michael jordan i'm
here uh can i talk to rex and she said
yeah right and hung up
and hung up on him
he called right back and he said no no
hey this is michael jordan and
i hear my sister go rex it's michael
jordan
and just real shitty and had to get off
she got off the phone real quick so i
could talk to michael and then mike will
ask me you know said hey i'm calling for
dean
um you know love for you to go to
carolina
i did end up going and visiting and had
a great visit
uh and then went to kentucky but then a
couple years later michael and i ended
up i ended up going with his
agent david falk so yeah we came we
became fast friends after that
i bet so and then so your time in the
nba
how did how did you keep a straight head
rex
you know your ascension in kentucky and
or you did not
i'm not sure if i did i i mean
if you mean straight head as a as
opposed to staying away from drugs and
alcohol i did that
um i i was always an addict
i think and when i think back basketball
addict first and foremost and you know
nobody
really has a problem with that because
it's
you know it's they think it's being
channeled all in the right direction and
you're it's good for you and all that
stuff but
i was really really one dimensional and
i didn't really know who i was or what i
was outside of basketball you know and i
started having a family my wife and i
ex-wife and i we married for 20 years
four great kids
um but you know playing in the nba is a
weird existence
it's not real life it's um it's just
i feel very fortunate to have done it
and and
it was what i wanted to do however there
were a lot a lot of it was kind of like
be careful what you wish for
i didn't want to be i didn't want to be
interviewed every day
i didn't want to do other things except
play basketball
and that's not all you have to do in
professional sports you gotta
you've got to do things the other things
so it took me a while to learn all that
and i
i kind of rebuffed it at first i don't
know that i was the most approachable
young athlete
um and sure in fact i know i wasn't you
know i would play aloof
a lot of the times with the media just
so they wouldn't talk to me
and i i think i suffered suffered from
social anxiety
you know for much of my life so being
around people that i didn't know
or that just knew me from basketball
that's always been kind of awkward and
i've i've
you know walk out of the house i from
the time i was 15
i've been recognized in this state and
you know pretty much everywhere
i go in in sporting circles so and
that's not always
comfortable i've learned to you know
handle it better
uh but i you know
back to your question what did i do i
what i did
i learned how to be an addict i i went
from
playing during the season and whenever i
wasn't playing during the season i was
at the racetrack
you know if we played in new york and i
had a day off i was going to aqueduct
and i was spending my day at aqueduct
and if we were going to be a day in
philly i was going to the otb
in philly and if we were going to golden
state i was going to be at golden gate
fields
so i was playing horses my whole life
was gambling
playing horses playing golf and
playing basketball and that's what i did
season to season to season the season
this season
for 12 or 13 years i had three surgeries
my last
seven years of playing and i wasn't very
good
my last my last year i felt like i was
going to retire at the end of the year
and i had an emergency appendectomy and
a doctor gave me
i got off the plane in phoenix doctor
gave me oxycontin
and you know i've had surgeries before
i'd
been on pain medicine before very
briefly but i
i didn't really like it because i knew i
had to get back playing and i needed to
know if that hurt or not i couldn't have
it you know
numb i needed to know if it was going to
be all right
well aft with this oxycontin he gave it
to me
and within two days rich i i i was in
love
i i felt like i was
smarter funnier better husband better
dad
more just it was all a lie
but this drug had a hold of me that fast
and if i fast forward about 18 months
a hellish 18 months danny ainge has come
to me
our danny ainge with the celtics good
good friend
of mine and uh has come to me and said
rex you're a mess man you're throwing
your whole life away
you've got a drug problem and you've got
to go away
and i thought i
i kind of i was kind of mad
like who that's how lost i was though
this guy is looking out for me and i was
like what business is it of yours
however he's the best person i've ever
known
maybe and somehow through
and at the time i was taking
about 40 viking in a day and about 10
oxycontin a day
jeez rex yeah and i was just eating them
i you know and again i didn't drink
uh i was just chewing them up to get
them into my system and with the
oxycontin their time release
so when you break that time release it's
you're off to the races
and that you know obviously that's how
people die they snort this stuff
they inject it um i was fortunate never
to do that
uh and then sorry about my dog in the
back no it's okay i've got two here too
richard yeah
and so um yeah uh
but that medicine it just took a hold
and uh i went to rehab
and um i got off the medicine but i had
another surgery shortly thereafter
six months later i was back on the
viking i never went back on the
oxycontin ever again it was just a
monster of a drug but i
was back on painkillers again
and really rich in and out of that for
about 15 years
until 2014 i was arrested
got in trouble was and every time i
every time i talk about this
yes it's therapy therapeutic but it does
make me want to cry
arrested for shoplifting in an apple
store
do you own or rent your home sure you do
and i bet it can be hard work
you know what's easy bundling policies
with geico
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com
[Applause]
you know this this pod is born out of
the pandemic turning people's lives
upside down but
painkiller addiction is is is a scourge
in this country still is
and you know i wanted to get your your
sense
that uh to try and help people
in that regard and that's what you do so
well you do that so much
rex i know you're you're being you know
modest right there with a little head
bob but it's true so you know and i kind
of wanted to give you a second for
yourself
what was it that was at that moment that
that was the lowest moment for you
that that's returned for you was getting
arrested i think
you know again if i go back and it's
really really diff you know hard
emotionally to go back because
you know my two older kids well they're
28
26 22 and 20 boy girl girl girl
the two older ones were kind of together
the two younger ones were a little bit
together you know
for much of the little girls lives i was
not very good
i was you know i was uh
on painkillers and so when i was
arrested
you know my my son was in college my
daughter was in college but these two
younger girls
were in middle school and high school
and
just the the guilt that i still carry
over putting them through this going to
school their dad who's you know
people knew me in phoenix they you know
i'd just
been playing ball there i'd live been
living there for 20 years
that embarrassment you know i'd let
myself down
more than anything i i had never
in my life come across something that
that
just could take me out i never even knew
something was out there that could do
that and that
that kind of it i'm glad i know it but
it
it also it's scary because you
you know you can you can be back there
if you don't watch out
and so um yeah you know
you brought up a good point about the
pandemic um
and i it's really strange retiring
at age 32 or 35 or
38 if you're lucky enough to uh at 32
whenever anybody asks me what are you
going to do
all through playing i always said i'm
just going to play golf and chase my
kids around
that was great for about a year also it
would have been great if i hadn't been
on drugs at that point but i was
um over the last year though rich
one of my one i won't say his name but
one of my really good buddies
uh one of my moral compasses that
that i've grown up with my whole life
guy he's an amazing dude emotionally
just right there and you know almost
never had a bad day in his life
and the pandemic came
he went through a tough time in his
relationship
his dad died he called me one day
and you know he's he's thinking about
retiring here in a few years
and he called me one day just down and
said hey man you ever
you ever feel down like you
you don't know what's wrong you feel
like you should be somewhere else but
you don't know where that is
i said every day every minute
and he said i said you know mike you're
also going through something
where you've been home and
your experience a little bit of
retirement right now it's kind of be
careful what you wish for you work all
that time and your routine and
he's a worker bee too and he likes to
work and all of a sudden that stuff's
taken away and when that's gone this is
like
playing basketball your whole life when
that's gone
you go in the morning and you know
whenever you retire
whatever it's from yeah i'm sure you're
but you're gonna go through
there's a there's a void there that
you've got to fill somehow
and if you're not prepared to fill it
right then and there you can really veer
off trap
so what do you say to people rex i mean
again
that's that's one of the well that's
what i'm saying is that that's one of
the reasons why i
i dubbed the name of this podcast just
getting started because there's so many
different meanings to it
where you can get restarted or you're
just getting started on something
completely new
business-wise as you point out your
friend is about to just get started on
trying
having to find uh a new life after being
a worker bee
what do you say to somebody who is
dealing with
either an addiction or needing to fill
that
void and has a family that
you know that you feel like you're
disappointed or you're you're needing to
make sure that
you can keep things going for what do
you what do you say
what do you what can you man advice i
think the
the hardest thing especially coming from
an athletic background is asking for
help
and you know a lot of us a lot of
athletes think that they're invincible
and
that you know i've done this on my own
and you know you really haven't you've
had
coaches and teammates and all that stuff
all the teachers everybody that's helped
you get to where you are
and uh addiction is something that is
virtually impossible to dig out of on
your own and so you've got to reach out
and ask for help and if you're
struggling with addiction you've got to
get clean
however that is and i don't you know i i
don't know whether it's 12 step
12 step doesn't work for everybody it
wasn't particularly my
my thing but it did get me uh off of
medicine and to a place where i could
start
taking stock of me as a person with
therapy
uh talking to a therapist that's been
the biggest uh one of the biggest things
for me i had to learn you know kind of
who i was what i liked to do
things that were good for me um
and the biggest thing is not isolating
you know
get out there i think also
rich playing a sport you know is
it's sort of surreal i mean all of my
friends dreamed of it
i dreamt of it they all did they all you
know
prayed at night to be 6'5 and
athletic and then i i was able to do
that
and there's not a day that goes by that
i don't think about how fortunate i am
but then there's you know i there's some
part of me that
that feels kind of guilty about it too
that you know why me
and then uh on top of that
being at sort of that high where
you know you can get 10 10 points in a
minute and force a coach to call a
timeout that he didn't want to burn
there's a high to that that really is
difficult to replace
and no matter what you do in life i
don't know that you're gonna have
that particular you know emotion
and so you got to be willing you got to
know that not everything's going to be
that exhilarating
but there's so much more out there if
you don't isolate
continue to be curious continue to you
know continue to
talk to your smart friends that's that's
been
one of my biggest biggest keys i have a
lot of smart friends somehow that have
helped me along the way and guided me
through things you know i'm a college
dropout i don't have a degree
i've had to learn a lot of stuff from
from my friends
i think we can all agree that running to
the store has been pretty stressful
lately
and there's nothing worse than
forgetting something on your list and
needing to make multiple trips
shopping for home essentials should be
easy and convenient and that's where
grove collaborative comes in
grove is the online marketplace that
delivers healthy home
beauty and personal care products
directly to you
with grove you don't have to shop
multiple stores or search endlessly
online and get all the natural goods you
need for you and your family plus
shipping is fast and free on your first
order
join over 2 million households who have
trusted grove collaborative to make
their homes
happier and healthier so again making
the switch to natural products has never
been easier
for a limited time when my listeners go
to grove dot co
slash eisen you'll get to choose a free
gift with your first order of thirty
dollars or more
but you have to use our special code go
to
dot co slash eisen to get your exclusive
offer
that's grove dot co slash e-i-s-e-n
[Applause]
so um how wild is it for you rex
that there's a whole legion of people
out there
who probably don't know you played
basketball
that you honestly i mean you have found
a platform
through twitter and social media that
has collected a large group of people i
see who retweets you
i mean i i follow people from politics i
follow people
from uh movies tv i just follow people
who's
who put interesting things in my
timeline with enough
uh positivity that's that's what i do
and obviously i followed you because i
knew
you from sports and then i really
enjoyed your style the block and charge
stuff really
got me involved that's how you drew me
in yeah
but you know there are a ton of people
out there who might be like
he played basketball i mean how how does
that hit you because you have and
you have restarted in that respect
right yeah yeah very very weird i i was
at the uh
uh nba rookie combine
a few years ago and uh um
you know i i was just out there guys
were coming out on the court
it was the year with taco fall and those
guys i
just remember him walking out on court
and a kid came up to me from uh
from tennessee that i'd covered
all season long grant williams now plays
for the celtics
and he came up to me and said hey
because he saw my
id i had said rex chapman on my lanyard
and he said your ex chapman i said yeah
he said the guy from twitter
i said yeah yeah
that's great that's this that's who i am
another time it happened was at the sec
tournament i had to go get my credential
and i've made my way to the bowels of
the you know in nashville wherever they
had it they had a bunch of interns there
19 20 21 year old interns i gave him my
id
and i saw him back there kind of looking
at it and whispering and the guy came
back and said
are you the guy from twitter now like
yeah
that's me i thought for sure but in that
moment i just wanted my id
i wanted my credential and i thought for
sure he's going to be like the
basketball player
like yeah that's me no the guy from
twitter the guy from twitter
so how did blocker charge start because
i mean is it just a bunch of nut shots
that you found on twitter and
basically um i would one day
a couple of years ago and i may have
mentioned this to you before
on your other show um i was really down
on on the political climate
twitter i felt was toxic social media
was toxic i was just
over it this was a two or three years
ago
and um i want it off but you know in
this sort of
line of business you kind of need some
sort of social media presence people you
work for
kind of want that as well it helps and
one day
seriously just scrolling through the
internet and i saw
a video of a school of dolphins swimming
into shore while a guy was paddle
boarding out
and right as he's paddle boarding uh
over a wave one of the dolphins jumped
up hit him in the chest
knocked him off the paddleboard and i
said to myself aloud that's a [ __ ]
charge
and and
for whatever reason i tweeted it out
people thought it was funny
and then i just started kind of doing
that blocker charge
and it took the pressure off right i
don't have to be clever i don't have to
talk about politics no nothing just
locker charge a little fun you know
people but you can only show them
so much of people just getting brutally
punished
and i always enjoyed it because like i
for the for the first few times that i
saw it rex i was
actually looking to see if their feet
were right you know
like i was actually trying to be literal
about it
and then it was just like screw it you
know it could be a block could be a
charge could be both who knows
who's traveling yeah who's on offense
that's the other part about it we don't
know
because there was one with a dog like a
child was like just stan
the child did just stop when the dog
pushed
the child over that's right that's right
that is a charge i mean he stopped
you know i was looking for a semi-circle
i was looking to see if there was you
know outside the line
outside oh my gosh so damn funny
and then you know um now it's
interesting you are
really political rex and um
you know so do you think you would have
if your sensibilities now were installed
in the player because there's so much
that does go on right now
the whole concept of shut up and dribble
or
should should players speak their mind
personally i think players and
your perfect attestment to that is you
know you're humans
so you you can talk it's not like you
know you
before you take your three-point shot
turn around to the camera and start
talking about
something that could be the right or
left side of the aisle you
you're performing but the question is is
what what what is your stance on all of
that rex
before you hit send on on that
yeah you know i'm i'm really proud of
what
our our nba what our league has done
um you know i think we've sort of set
the set the mark
for the professional sports leagues and
of
um you know being socially conscious
conscious what the guys did in the
bubble what the
ladies did last year the wnba players i
think had a huge part
in the political landscape of this
country i think that
uh i think in no large part uh
to these guys thanks goes to them
i think there's a chance that what
they've done
over the last year speaking their minds
being
thoughtful about what they're talking
about making sense
led to a change in power in washington
mitch mcconnell's no longer
uh in power there and i bring him up
only because he's been a senator
in the state of kentucky since i was a
15 year old junior in high school
and you know i make no bones about it
i'm not a mitch mcconnell fan
i'm very uh i'm very appreciative for
what the nba
has done and what these guys have done
also it's very brave
it's very brave there are things i wish
i would have spoken up on
you know race wise 30 years ago
that i didn't have i didn't have the
courage i didn't have the understanding
i didn't have the confidence
um and i'm not sure i had the money
the thing with guys now that's the thing
i'm not sure these guys have the money
it's it's more important than that you
know what we saw
over the last year with george floyd and
brianna taylor right here in
my backyard in louisville um
i thought i was just shocked
and i'm i'm appreciative of the stance
that the nba has taken and i'm
appreciative of adam silver for
uh his leadership and um
and then you know the aspect that i
think
has caused much uh of your following
to explain expand and blossom rex
is just the positivity that you'll
you'll put in
um i love it you know it's certainly in
this day and age
again maybe a podcast about
argument or um inflaming
or talking about an issue that is
divisive
um in in in a manner that is um
exclusionary we see that a lot we see i
mean we see in sports the
the the the you know split screen
and then the topic bar about something
that's totally outrageous i i i
i don't know i i kind of that's my
competition almost every day
i know you know but i i wanted to talk
about something positive
here and i mean where do you find some
of these videos some of these
beautiful videos of humanity and then of
course you know you had me with the
first dog video too
my wife has even sent here take a
picture of our dog and send it to rex
maybe you'll post it
like literally that has happened so
where do you find them rex
man at first i get at first i guess well
again
you know i i you can only beat people
over the head with block or charge so
much you can only
beat them over the head with political
stuff so much whether
whether you're on their side or not you
know
before long it just becomes white noise
and so
you know we're all human and i
most of us many of us are are pet people
um i'm not so much into cats but my
daughter
loves cats so i have to love cats as
well now um
by the way i love how you tiptoe around
that stuff because you know
you know cat people when somebody says
i'd rather just not be around a cat you
know
i know that's you just i just love out
of all the subject matters that we've
hit
directly in this podcast
you just tiptoed around criticizing cats
i know i didn't want to just come
straight out and say cats or [ __ ]
just i'm just saying that you know mix
in the feel-good stuff
and you know i guess i did spend more
time a while back
looking for stuff trying to find stuff
anymore i'm so lucky rich because i'll
i'll
go work out i'll get up get done and
there's five people that i know
strictly from twitter who've sent me
five just beautiful feel-good stories
and i gotta kind of pick at that point
and then maybe just put a little
wording behind it it's really easy at
this point i'm very fortunate
none of the content is mine i am i have
such good friends and such good people
out there in
the twitter sphere that just send me
great stuff it's awesome
so you you get just unsolicited here's
some videos i found and they give it to
you because they know that you've got
the platform you'll hit it out
there yeah yeah that is so cool can you
drop a name if you don't mind like who
have you
who have you got to know through twitter
that you don't think you'd ever
have gotten to know potentially through
oh
everybody uh i remember waking up to a
um now mind you i lived in my car for a
few days a few years ago five six seven
years ago now
uh but i woke up one morning here not
long ago
and had a message a direct message from
sasha baron cohen
and really and it was about
it was about trump and how it was after
the january 6th thing
and uh he was really as many of us were
hoping that twitter would ban him and he
asked for my help
i put out a couple tweets i amplified
his tweets and in a couple days
the man was off of twitter um so that
sort of blows me away
a guy like sasha baron cohen who forget
what you know about him as an actor
that's a brilliant human being on a
different on a different level
kind of brilliant uh so things like that
when i look up and i see
i don't know uh nancy pelosi's following
my account or um you know
some leader from another you know new
zealand
i i don't it i don't understand really
how it happened
and many of these people like i had jane
lynch on
the actress jane lynch on our pod
the other day and she had no idea she
just knows me from twitter
she knows josh hopkins mr josh hopkins a
little bit from the acting world
but she has no idea who i you know that
i've played sports or anything she just
knows me from twitter
which is surreal and i'm finding more
and more that the other part that i'm
finding like you said rich
we're all kind of searching especially
right now we've been shut down for a
year and we're
searching for that community i think a
lot of this has been you know
kind of therapeutic you get together
with like-minded individuals and
you know i think you want to be
challenged in this
social media space somewhat by people
who know more than you do
that's what i look for i don't want to
just follow dummies like me i want to
follow people smarter than me
and connecting with people like that
through
twitter has just been phenomenal
let's talk sleep number right now folks
why choose proven quality sleep from
sleep number
because a good night's rest helps boost
immunity improve recovery and increase
energy many of us don't realize that our
daytime habits drastically impact the
quality of our shut-eye
when we devote small moments throughout
the day to recharging
we set ourselves up to get the quality
sleep we need
so try adding one or all of these micro
steps to your daily routine for more
restorative sleep
charge your phone outside of the bedroom
read books in bed to calm your mind
try morning yoga or meditation schedule
monthly mental health days and truly log
off i mean truly
log off proven quality sleep is
life-changing sleep
introducing the new sleep number 360 p5
smart bed the queen now
only at 1 799
only at sleep number stores or
sleepnumber.com
isaac
[Applause]
so before i let you go rex just a little
bit of fun here best player
you ever lit up in a game
who's the best player this is the trick
question
no who's the best player you ever lit up
in a game right i guess
i guess jordan michael you lit up
michael in a game
yeah yeah i did normally when people say
that i say which time
[Laughter]
um pardon me if there's this if there's
a famous moment where you lit up jordan
that i
that i that i that that i memory hold
for some reason no go ahead
yeah i think yeah well we did i i i um
we beat them when they were 72 and 10
uh or 70 72 and 10. is that the last
dance the last dance bulls that's right
okay yeah and so we played them at our
place in miami we only had eight players
available because we just made a trade
and um they came to our place
uh down at south beach and they were out
when i say they were out all night
they they thought this is an easy win
you know we were 41 and 41 that year and
they swept us in the first round of the
playoffs
like we were a jv team 3-0 you know the
best three
three out of five but this is about a
month before all of that
and when i say they were partying on
south beach all night i know they were
because i was there
with them and so we
we uh we sneaked them we sneaked them
the next night at our place i got 39
and we won and uh gave them one of their
uh losses for for that season and then
we actually played them about two weeks
later in another regular season game
and michael and i have known each other
forever and
uh the jump ball went up and threw the
ball
up and he went and cracked me in the
sternum with an elbow
right from the get-go where i went oh
[ __ ] and i went
i guess it's going to be like that all
night and guess what
it was he got like 40 and three quarters
didn't play the fourth and i went like
three for 13 and had 13 points something
like that
but yeah there you go here you would
probably he would probably be the best
one i would
i'll tell you what rex you know and this
is the problem with conversations
you know um certainly between
generations about comparing all-time
greats because that means
if you take the approach of one better
than the other it does
insinuate that the other is less than
you're
denigrating an all-time great but
the lebron versus michael conversation
to me you know when you speak to
somebody who knows both errors
um you know it is it is a no-brainer as
far as
i'm concerned but then you talk to a
younger generation of somebody who
never saw michael play and they're so
insistent
that lebron is head and shoulders above
michael
it's it it it's i i kind of have to hold
back i don't mean
i don't mean to be like that i don't
want to be that old man like you you
never saw this man play but
you never saw this man play you know
what i'm right
and i think i think we all come at it
from our own little window of
perspective when i say that
it's like i i think michael's the best
too of course
however lebron is creeping into that
conversation for me
i mean he he's he's amazing and he's
never made a misstep
he never and forget about the decision
and all that stuff
dude has never made a misstep i'm a huge
huge fan
and especially of everything that he
does off the court
so uh that's a huge plus um
you know isaiah thomas famously
he he doesn't revere michael the way
or you know and even when you talk to
him off offset you know
he's not denigrating michael he's just
saying he didn't become
michael jordan and he didn't until
isaiah and then were kind of gone
until that right at the end he didn't
real michael didn't ascend he had to go
through them
and so and they were younger or isaiah
and them were
older it's like when people ask me about
kobe
and i i played against michael and kobe
played against older michael the young
michael i played against young kobe
i saw what kobe became unbelievably good
but i could never put him with michael
and maybe that's just because i'm older
you know it is kind of get off my lawn
um so i think it's
it's so difficult to distinguish michael
was just so
different his mindset
his killer mentality and then the thing
that really
his bounce was elite but his hands
i mean um
we went bowling one night before a game
in chicago
and a bunch of us a bunch of his buddies
and
and we're you know how you you'll be
bowling
and uh you'll roll one ball
come back the pins didn't reset and you
gotta roll another ball down to clear
the
lane just just roll another ball down
there and so michael's telling a story
he's got his back to the pins and we
alert him that hey they
need to roll a ball down the lane to
reset the pins
and he looked back he reached over he
picked up a 17-pound bowling ball
not with the holes he palmed it back
handed it down the lane
and i just i looked at everybody else
and they went
oh you didn't know he could do that i
went [ __ ] no i didn't know he could do
that
did he clear it with one shot or well he
didn't even have to hit anything he just
rolled it you know rolled it
back oh i thought i thought you said he
was going to clear like a 7 10 split
that way and i'm like
what no but i mean when you see guys do
that and michael
he knew what he was doing too he was
great with coming up
and giving you a great big uh dap
hand handshake before the game because
his hand just
enveloped your whole arm it was an
intimidation ploy
you know it really did and when you see
him pushing off of
brian russell yeah against utah you
don't understand what
that little that hand is so big
and it just it's like a vice grip and
just there for a moment all he needs is
that little push
to get you off get you off of him he was
a
he was a freak of nature physically um
i feel fortunate to have stories to tell
about him i mean it was
it was a joy playing against it so i
mean
yeah i thought russell was supposedly he
slipped you're
you're saying michael shoved him he
might have got him
for his last dance shot i mean
wow again yeah you're breaking this
break this is going to go over great in
utah uh hey rex
thanks for the uh for the time really
appreciate it who's on your pod this
week with mr josh hopkins who's on
we've got jamal mashburn this week
and next week we're going to have stefan
wardell curry
young stefan stefan's coming on the pod
dude
he is on fire i just wish he was playing
better right now
i know what i'm talking about you could
make a case that he's
he's never been better right now i i i'm
anxious to talk to him because i really
felt like
last year or two years ago right before
he broke his hand
i felt like he was playing the best
basketball he's ever been playing and it
looks like he's just kind of
rounding back into into into form well
rex uh everyone can get your pod where
all podcasts are acquired the rex
chapman show you in mr josh hopkins and
rex
uh uh i'm be thrilled to be able to call
you a friend uh i
appreciate it please have me i was about
to jamaal mashburn followed by steph
curry
i mean i i i can maybe beat my kids in
knockout i don't know if that's okay to
to any time for come on i'd love to
anytime i'd love to have you rich
i'll have you have me on right after the
draft we can talk about that and all the
good stuff with st
jude because i know that you're into the
positivity of what's going on so
i appreciate it rex anytime rich thank
you buddy that's rex chapman right here
on just getting started
good lord i love rex chapman man i'm i'm
sure we can have him back on and he's
got stories for days and
again what's uh what's uh become
of him after his downfall
and you know as somebody who's in this
chair i have
you know a choice to just let him get
emotional over
you know his shoplifting arrest and you
know for those who are listening right
now you can
see by the way every episode of this on
the rich eisen show youtube
page youtube.com richardson show our
entire archive is there and
you know he was getting emotional he's
putting his hands on his eyes and i
think he was tearing up
and um i decided to give him a minute
he tells the story sometimes not all the
time but
it is um
it's tough because i'm sure a lot of
people like to poke fun in his direction
and certainly when he posts something
that
does not jive with someone's political
point of view
or uh their viewpoint of the direction
of our country i'm sure that's what they
throw in his face
and for someone to be so positive on
twitter which we all know can be a total
complete
cesspool it is remarkable his positivity
that he has and if you don't follow rex
chapman you should
and um that's one of the reasons why i
want to have my man so
positive and what a story that he that
he has uh
you know and and what i mentioned about
saint jude um
my annual run that i run every single
year in my suit and tie at the combine
there was no combine this year because
of what was going on in the world
and so um i uh i
i didn't know if i was gonna have my run
this year
for um for many reasons
because i didn't know when we could do
it i didn't know you know when it could
air
i didn't know anything other than the
fact that i wanted to do it in some way
shape or form because it's now done on
behalf of saint jude children's research
hospital
so uh it's gonna get announced later on
wednesday
um on the 21st i don't know when
everyone might be listening to this
podcast on april
uh on the april docket but
um that's when we're planning on
announcing it the it being
me running for st jude children's
research hospital this year
with the run airing during the nfl draft
and me
having not won not two but 16
other people run it with me i can't give
out too much more information right now
on this show but what i would love for
everyone to do
is go to saintjude.org slash
run richrun and donate give whatever you
can
every single dollar counts because
st jude children's research hospital
everything they do there is donation
based and the everything that they do
there
is get sick kids better people come from
all over the country to go to saint jude
and what's covered
for the families who go to the campus at
memphis tennessee of saint jude
children's research hospital
they cover everything they cover health
care
they cover the costs of traveling
to and from saint jude they cover
lodging they cover room and board food
they cover
everything for every family so they
don't have to worry
about picking up their lives and leaving
their jobs to go with their children
who have just gotten the nightmare
diagnosis for all parents out there
the nightmare diagnosis that the sudden
pain in their leg or their sudden pain
in their
arm or their sudden blurriness of vision
their sudden inability to
stay upright that they're losing their
balance is in fact something
born out of cancer or a disease that
needs
immediate assistance
and saint jude brings everyone there and
makes sure they never see a bill so
all the families focus on is the
children
getting better and they also
that's why they call it research
hospital they also
make sure that kids don't get to
don't have to go to saint jude because
the research that they do there
makes these cancers more curable
so saint jude is a place that's heaven
on on earth to say the least
and that's why i run for him and this
year's run
is going to be special because of the 16
people who are running with me
i've got some assistance uh we're
running in the home of the super bowl
super bowl 56
um here in los angeles so five stadium
at hollywood park
i'll throw that one out there for
everybody here on just getting started
and we just ran it this past weekend i'm
in one piece i'm happy to say
my time has been filed for 2021
and i have a pretty
darn group of humans and players
who ran with me to raise some money
so we're going to show you the contents
of that on the nfl draft i'll do another
pod next week before i leave for ohio
for the nfl draft right around the
corner
um but for everyone here on just getting
started i want to thank rex chapman and
we'll
see you next week